welcome to this 15-minute game playing
ends super awesome one yes sometimes
remarked there are many awesome handles
but there are not many people calling
some solver I don't know total mega fool
people don't have the sense of humor I
guess okay so let's see them classical
variation here of the of the NIMS oh I'm
playing with cattle than t5 trying the
slide it's one of those lines that is
some get towards very quick development
I kind of played c5 maybe maybe I should
have played c5 okay this isn't also also
a normal way to play with Bishop a6
coming this is how kramnik played a
number of times the only problem like
slight problem from a practical point of
view is that Jung there are some some
variations here that are very really
very dry but white has to play one of
those first if he's not really knowing
what's going on Liam and black can get a
very nice play quickly due to the good
development I really don't know the
theoretical details so I need to meet
you yeah work it out over the board
yeah Knight f3 looks really normal I
also think that gothic neither three is
the Normans Bishop f6 I take with the
Queen okay he's checking here
interesting I am I have not quite sure
and what happens here I can play Bishop
a6 CI a-- if we take c 7 i'll take d for
this this must be fine for me this fine
for black ok come and that's not big use
and spending time on that Bishop a six
is the normal development anyway and if
he is not taking over one then what what
kind of idea was this you cannot really
go I can go to a FOIA okay the sea can
do maybe maybe queen a form
Quincy 724 I think should be very okay
for black I'm really really a nicely
developed and attack be 297 rook c8 this
kind of moves are coming that's in fact
a general problem of the the classical
variation with Queen see to it is very
well founded line but it has one known
one drawback the development of the
Kings side is Sir neglected as we can
see quite clearly hear the Queen side is
totally open and the King side is just
like at the beginning of the game and
this can really sometimes cost white
dearly the some development problems
okay so let's see what what am i doing
after Queen Queen a form i think
probably that night dear that Queen d7
is probably a good reply Queen d7 night
bd7 is not a problem I can always place
your five later Oh is really retreating
interesting
hmm
interesting so probably just night B to
D seven young Queen c7 is not really a
problem i can now i can really just take
and play rook c8 play for the
development this should be okay all the
time with the superior pieces and queen
c7 that's also just a queen movement and
a whoop caf okay maybe 97 to get NC 5 I
can also play see 5 immediately also
nice move actually see 5 now but ok this
is this is certainly not not bad ya know
is taking and diamond into doing that
immediately I wonder why
okay so let's let's consider one thing
is the total exchange sham yeah yes I
can take c7 rook FCA truck takes the aid
rook c8 and this is an excellent
development it always should be enough
to compensate but I wonder if there is
something something even better yeah
again I would like to play Queenie 7 but
he has Bishop takes f6 Bishop f6 is so
not so not so great to to face you seven
Bishop f6 gfx he's got to check on g3 I
would still have good compensation but
it's not so convincing okay let's trade
and play walks eh this should be a good
anyway
I don't believe in Roxy one I have 90
form against that
check
yeah and yeah how do you develop now
kingdom one may be covering see to but I
have 94 just one one way to go now okay
94 Bishop e3 em and then f3 but ok so he
actually allow us Roxy to yeah maybe
just just enter them before he plays
king d one after all King d1 was
interesting I mean I have ideas am like
Bishop c3 as Bishop c4 bliss recheck and
so on but still maybe King be one was
more interesting one problem of course
is that a move like III is not possible
at all due to Roxy one winning winning
the bishop on everyone
yeah so nitey for I guess it looks this
looks very normal very natural and
centralizing the night yeah pretty much
asking the bishop where do you go now
after Bishop f4 for example I can play
rook a to threatening rook a one with me
to follow and I don't really know what
is playing against that how is it how
what what is he doing against it now
that that's already very problematic a
disposition very tough to hold forward
so Luke a Jew is playing what exactly
kindy one maybe
don't don't you enough to threaten
checkmate I always like to do that the
most the crudest way possible but if
it's a good move and you threaten
something directly very often you should
do that yeah I guess kingly one I mean
not not not a nice but kindy one then
I'm absolutely not sure what to do I
probably Knight f6 I don't I don't want
to take early materially I mean I def
64's also very nice
and there are any King do you want i
also have Knight c3 check which is
interesting King c1 and then I just need
somewhere the bishop to a for Roxy to
checkmate hook funny this is the
lowering a mate check and I'm doing that
and okay it's the planking you wanna put
the price up this wasn't the most subtle
threat Nate but that it was already I
think beyond saving and I really don't
think there is any any way out there
yeah kingdom one I thought 90 of six
would be interesting but this is also
also am very valid threatening if it
does nothing I'm through I'm going champ
and going for direct media routes you to
checkmate yeah and this this will not
end well yeah okay h4s is ridiculous
just a simple move and this is the
computer suggestion to continue yeah I
why this just totally clobbered down
here so just one possibility i thought
this was also interesting okay in fact
the computer now gives an even better
innovation evaluation for that move yeah
it's just the the old rule yeah improve
your worst piece the night on d 7 is not
attacking and once it joins the action
this is the the top line of the comp g3
what the position so just take him check
winning the rook in the corner yeah this
is simply wasn't her wasn't playable
this pawn grab I don't think rook see
one is such a great idea to start with
maybe I'd here probably probably to go
here with some nothing better than the
22 to go down again this is just super
super risky that was surprised that he
played this in eight seconds he had
other other ways to go i mean even this
means hot stranger that looks comes into
consideration as it blocks the seaport
for for some time this this however is
just leading to two big trouble already
and this i don't think is possible King
d1 the certainty necessary and then I
thought him I wasn't I wasn't totally
sure here but after this i probably have
I have this move f 3 95 m yeah fantastic
position yeah it's it it's just a strong
attack even with quite some material
traded Czech government after this i
think it's it's basically gone yeah
blackest black is just break is winning
here okay this was a blunder but it's
not much fun to defend in any case okay
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching